vous lisez en titre l'arménie et la
turquie ont fait un premier pas
important vers la réconciliation assuré
qu'ils ont signé un accord visant à
rétablir leurs relations diplomatiques
et cela après un siècle de tensions
entre les deux pays christian hottin
cette signature met fin à près d'un
siècle de confrontations entre la
turquie et l'arménie
les diplomaties américaine et française
n'ont pas ménagé leurs efforts le
suspens aura duré jusqu'au bout en cause
l'évocation des massacres d'arméniens
finalement pour régler le différend
aucune allocution ne sera prononcée ce
traité de normalisation prévoit la
réouverture des frontières entre la
turquie et l'arménie ainsi que
l'ouverture d'ambassades un accord qui
rencontre une forte opposition dans les
deux pays
hier dans la capitale arménienne
plusieurs milliers de personnes
manifestaient contre cet accord cette
signature fait l'impasse sur la
reconnaissance internationale du
génocide arménien en question le
massacre et la déportation d'arméniens
entre 1915 et 1917 par les troupes de
l'empiré ottoman plus d'un million et
demi de victimes des faits contestés par
la turquie qui refuse le terme de
génocide
l'autre point d'achoppement concerne le
haut karabakh cette enclave annexée par
l'arménie en 1993 après une guerre de
six ans l'azerbaïdjan qui réclame la
restitution de ce territoire à
d'ailleurs dénoncé l'accord d'hier soir
pour entrer en vigueur le traité de
normalisation doit être avalisé par les
parlements turc et arménien une
procédure qui devrait prendre plusieurs
semaines